- Yeah, okay.
- 'Cause once Uber realizes
a large portion of their drivers
are under our control,
they'll have no choice but to
listen to your demands.
- Very smart, very smart.
- And at that point, you can
tell them,
"Get rid of that onesie."
- Knock them down.
That's the best idea.
I love you, man.
- I, uh...I love you too.
Okay, so I think that's good for
today.
- Okay.
- I'd never started a sleeper
cell before.
But in doing some research
online,
I learned that the key to
running any clandestine cell
operation is having a
communication structure that
kept the identities of the
leaders secret.
That way, if any of our sleeper
agents were compromised,
they wouldn't be able to rat us
out to Uber
and bring down the cell.
From now on, we couldn't risk
using our personal phones.
We'd have to get prepaid burner
phones.
So to make sure the purchase
couldn't be traced back to us,
I anonymously hired someone off
Craigslist
to go to a local Walgreens and
told him there would be cash
hidden in a dirty McDonald's
cup outside the location,
which he was to use to buy up
the store's entire supply
of prepaid cell phones.
The Craigslist guy was told to
then bring the phones
to an abandoned pier at the San
Pedro harbor
at exactly 1:15 p.m.,
where he would find a
waterproof pouch hidden
inside a white first aid kit at
the end of the dock.
He was then instructed to put
all the phones into the pouch,
hook the base of the pouch to a
nearby cinder block,
and throw it off the pier,
where unbeknownst to him,
I was awaiting the delivery in
full scuba gear
beneath the surface completing
the final step
of a burner phone purchase that
would be impossible
to trace back to either me or
Andy.
Now that we had a way to
communicate with our drivers,
we would need to figure out the
commands to give them.
So I started researching Uber
Yelp reviews
and online comments to see what
behaviors from drivers
customers hated the most.
The complaints ranged from
foul-smelling vehicles
to telling offensive jokes to
blasting terrible music.
But to know which combination
of these would be most
effective, we would need to
test them out
on actual Uber customers.
So I had Andy go undercover and
sign up for an Uber driver
account with his personal
vehicle.
And after taking it for a final
inspection
posing as an average Joe
looking to make
a few extra bucks on the side..
- Yeah, I'm just an average Joe,
make some money the side, you
know.
- Yeah, I'm a normal guy.
- Andy was now registered as a
fully accredited Uber driver.
And that meant we could begin
our test.
- "Playing bad music," yep.
"Bad smell, driver..."
Driver what?
- Gas.
- Oh, that's bad, yeah.
- What's the worst of these?
- The worst one's
driver gets lost--go 5 right?
You're supposed to go to 5
North, drive me 5 South.
That's it.
They're like, "No, it's crazy."
- Do you know how to do these,
like--
- Oh, of course.
I'm the master of these.
- You're already a bad driver?
No, I'm not bad driver,
but I have lots of experience.
- To simulate the smell of
driver farting,
I brought Andy box full of
ziplock bags
each filled with a sulfur-based
stink spray.
So it's, like, one per ride.
- Okay.
- They smell really bad.
- Oh, they--oh, okay.
- To test the effects of bad
music,
I gave him a burned CD with an
endless loop
of Lou Bega's 1999 hit "Mambo
No. 5" on it,
considered by many experts to
be one of
the worst songs ever made.
So with everything prepped,
Andy turned on his Uber app
and headed out
to pick up some customers.
- Hello. How are you?
- Fine. How about you?
What's your name?
- Lori.
- Lori, yeah.
- Well, it doesn't matter the
price.
How did it come out?
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
Excuse me. Can I--can we roll
down the window?
- Oh, the window doesn't work.
It's broken.
- It doesn't go down?
- No.
- Oh, 'cause it smells in here.
Oh, I'm in an Uber right now.
I'm going someplace, and the
window doesn't go down.
And it kind of smells in here.
[laughs].
So--oh, wait.
No, so I can't...
- Ladies and gentlemen,
this is mambo number five.
- Oh, wait. I'm on the phone.
I'm sorry. I'm on the phone.
Excuse me. Sir.
[upbeat music]
Sir, I'm on the phone.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna get out.
- ♪ One, two,
three, four, five ♪
- I'm getting out.
- The first ride lasted less
than a minute,
and after running through our
list
with several other customers...
- Yo, I think I'm lost, man.
- You're lost?
- The most intolerable Uber
driver behaviors
became clear.
- Turn off the music.
Cut it off.
Turn off the music.
♪ ♪